vraiment en avance je suis allé prendre
un café je discutais j'étais au
téléphone je me couche je regarde leur
bible je vais au maroc j'arrive mais
c'est fini gilles mais j'avais continué
disent ouais l'avion c'est mort vous ça
vous est déjà arrivé isabelle
morini-bosc m est déjà arrivé oui merci
maintenant je suis tout seul mais c'est
moi je suis toujours en avance mais
quand on est avec quelqu'un qui est dit
systématiquement retard j'ai un ami
journaliste qui était système est
rouverte armé de trois quarts d'heure ah
ouais et qui vous dit en plus garder mes
bagages donc vous n'osez pas abandonner
des bagages essayez ça c'est un
cauchemar absolu
sauf est une bonne émission aujourd'hui
où vous êtes et là il ya deux semaines
quoi se marrer c'est je partais au maroc
mais dites moi vous partez toutes les
semaines ouais c'est que ce n'est pas ce
moment je veux bouger un petit peu après
qu'il ait mal payés mais non non non
mais non j'étais les rater il arrive je
suis bien c'est un truc de fou date
j'étais pas la peine précise qui était
invité sa cuisse et un plus grand bar de
l'arrivée sont en avance je suis allé
prendre un café je discutais j'étais au
téléphone je me couche je regarde leur
vie mais je vais au maroc j'arrive mais
c'est fini gilles mai
[Rires]
et même aéroport quant à deux heures
d'avancé
tu as l'air aux portes à 12 heures
d'avancé tu as toujours une estrade le
louper tu crois toujours qu'il vont
taper un moment quand autant monsieur
hanouna monsieur hanouna moi ça m'arrive
de plein de fois ils m'appellent échoira
sera de ouf les mecs qui vont partir
sans moi moi j'ai jamais raté un avion
je suis toujours wave aussi thierry
bourgard est toujours en avance quand je
me suis écrasé mes bagages par un avion
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous allez encore un effort monsieur
moreau je revenais de rome pour un
séminaire de notre grande société où on
lagardère et j'étais le dernier sur le
tapis avec quelqu'un que vous connaissez
qui s'appellera mesures étaient comme
deux s'apprend patron du groupe la gala
bah du coup mon bagage une monnaie puis
après ils m'ont appelé m'ont dit
monsieur on a retrouvé j'ai eu deux
bonnes nouvelles une bonne et une
mauvaise on a retrouvé vos gardes
bagages oui très bien la mauvaise
nouvelle c'est qu'elle a été écrasée et
donc ils m'ont rendu un truc qu'on
pourrait rater et alors et vous allez
voir place et il me remplacer la bagages
mais pas l'intérieur parce que c'était
que des fringues j'avais plus bas vous
vous étiez plutôt tranquille on a mr
scoumoune avoue qu est ce qui vous est
arrivé je me suis fait voler mes bagages
mais devant moi non le gars est passé
avec mes bagages devant moi on s'est dit
mais il me vole mes bagages et le gris
vous avez fait rien fait n'a pas
réellement sidéré que le gars me vol les
bagages qui dit [ __ ] il vole mes
bagages
le temps de réaction quand même c'est
dans quoi elle donc essayer de marquer
avec mes deux valises en plus
ah ouais mais oui ils avaient tous nos
sacs j'ai alors moi je monte ma femme
may hamm est justifiée dans le rer
n'était pas capable de courir pour un
volant c'était il ya très longtemps là
il a changé depuis at était mon auto les
deux c'est super bizarre s'est jamais
retrouvé quoi j'ai dit à ma compagne on
vient de nous voler mes bagages à limete
comptes a rien fait j'ai dit banon le
gars est parti avec un expert de fou
[Musique]